players kneel before the national anthem
to protest systemic racism on major
league baseball's opening night
the washington redskins become the
washington football team and anthony
fauci throws out a first pitch and makes
sure that nobody catches anything
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn.com
ben well you know i learned my lesson a
few weeks ago i suggested that when i
watch
sports i actually like to watch sports i
know that sports are supposed to be a
distraction from everyday life that's
what the
goal of sports is in fact my friend clay
travis who hosts
over at outkick the coverage and over at
fox news at fox sports
he pointed out on this show that the
word sport comes from dysport the word
dysport
which comes originally from anglo french
which it used to mean divert or to amuse
literally it meant in old french to
carry away the mind from serious matters
that's what sport was
sport was a distraction no longer we
have entered
a new woke world and frankly i'm really
excited about it because here is what i
want here's what i want i want more
politics in sports i've decided the time
has come
i'm tired of all of this apolitical
mumbo jumbo where we all sort of get
together and just have a good time
and don't focus in on all the things
that divide us now i need everything to
be divisive i want
every single thing to divide americans i
want to turn on
a baseball game and the first thing i
want to see is i want to see political
platforms
laid forth by every single player i need
to know
what john mankata the second baseman for
the chicago white sox
i need to know what he second third base
trades off positions and because he has
two separate positions
on the field i need two separate policy
platforms as well i need to know what
john mankata thinks
about the payroll tax i need to know it
and if i don't know it before the game
starts i'm just not going to watch the
game
more than that i need every single
player to mouth platitudes about america
and how much america sucks i need
them to at exactly the tone and tenor
that i like
and if they don't i'm not gonna engage
i'm just not gonna watch
i'd be so angry i'm gonna suggest that
they are just not socially conscious
and if anyone else says to me you know i
just want sports to be a political i
know they're lying
i know they're lying because just by
saying they want sports to be apolitical
they're being political don't you see
right that isn't the national anthem
political isn't the flag
isn't everything political i want
everything to be political i am only
i pledge right here right now i am only
going to buy hvac parts
from ceos who agree with me politically
i am only going to be served by baristas
who mouth the slogans that i like if
somebody doesn't shout at me silence is
violence
well handing me my chips and and fish
i i'm simply not going to take i'm going
to slam that right down on the table and
walk out of the restaurant that is the
way
life is going to get better in this
united states we cannot have
any sort of common areas that are
apolitical because if we do then we
refuse to acknowledge the evils that go
along
uh that go on around us every area of
american life
must be infused with the nastiness and
polarization of american politics and
particularly
i want everybody to mount the slogan
that america sucks while simultaneously
taking part
in some of the most lucrative businesses
that the world has to offer
that's what the people i want to hear
from most are the people who are the
most privileged in our society
i i need to hear from people who earn
millions and millions of dollars i i
want to i'm desperate to hear from
people who earn millions of dollars
about how they are victimized in
american society and how american
society innately victimizes people who
are members of their group
i definitely need to hear about that i
want it you want it we all want it
and when i turn on baseball i don't care
so much about like whether somebody can
throw 100 miles an hour or can hit the
curve
what i really care deeply about is what
aaron judge
thinks about everything everything
ranging from america's china policy
to how exactly we handle restructuring
of social security
i need to know about it i do okay and so
i was super happy with
major league baseball's opening day i
mean i was just pumped about this
because they finally got the message we
finally rammed home the message guys
every single thing has to be political
every single thing we can't just in the
middle of a pandemic you know be
distracted by sport you know like the
world during world war ii when it was
considered kind of important
to have sports be there as a distraction
for the american public
because we were doing important things
at the same time no
they got it all wrong during world war
ii we didn't need major league baseball
to to just exist so that we could all be
distracted
and look at the box scores what we
really needed is for major league
baseball to be
extraordinarily political in every
possible way
we don't need sports as a distraction
it's no longer just sport sports is
politics politics is sports it's
all one giant agglomeration
of of anger and rage and that makes
america better i feel like
i feel like every time i have a
conversation with someone i disagree
with
we shouldn't be able to talk sports so
we can sort of distract ourselves and
remind ourselves what we have in common
as human beings
instead we should really just you know
club each other over the head about
politics that it's made the world better
that's how i felt on opening day i felt
so much better about america
knowing that extraordinarily rich
baseball players were kneeling
to protest in america's systemic racism
i i i felt i don't know about you i felt
great about it
great it was good stuff we'll get to
this in just one second the wonders
of watching a sport turns into basically
just msnbc
we'll get to that in a second first
let's talk about how you can lower your
cell phone bill by switching to pure
talk usa you can cut costs and free up
cash on a monthly basis starting with
your wireless provider
pure talk covers 99 of americans the
president and ceo of puretalk is a us
veteran who cares deeply about serving
americans by making
wireless affordable which is awesome
start your saving today
it'd be pretty weird not to save money
on your cell phone bill when you
absolutely can
one of the things that you get sold very
often is unlimited data you kind of
don't need unlimited data most people
don't use unlimited data
instead start saving today today dial
pound 250 say keyword ben shapiro for
unlimited talk unlimited text and
two gigs of data for just 20 bucks a
month plus you'll get 50
off your first month stop paying too
much to big wireless providers switch to
pure talk today say 50
off your first month style pound 250 say
keyword ben shapiro
that's pound 250 and say the keyword ben
shapiro pure talk usa simply smarter
wireless save a bundle
on the amount you're spending on your
cell phone bill and again when you dial
up pound 250 and say keyword bench
appear you get unlimited talk unlimited
text two gigs of data for 20 bucks a
month and
50 off that first month so it's just 10
bucks the first month now pound 250
say keyword ben shapiro so again i was
very pumped about the opening
of the baseball season it wasn't weird
enough that we have no fans in the
stands which by the way
is strange like why can't we socially
distance the fans they have these giant
stadiums
why exactly should we not be able to
socially distance any of the fans
but apparently we're not going to
instead we're just going to have these
weird empty stadiums which makes
baseball seem like golf but okay
okay i'm just glad that we're getting
back to sport i mean i listen i'm an mlb
tv subscriber
i love baseball it is my sport my white
socks are gonna be really interesting
this shortened season they have a bunch
of young up-and-coming players
so i was pretty pumped and then i got
even more pumped because i realized
not only was i gonna get baseball i was
going to get social justice warrior
messaging
with my baseball which is what i crave
it's what everybody craves we're already
getting it with basketball and with
football as we'll get to in just a
moment
but to get it with baseball which is my
personal favorite sport i
i loved it every single second so last
night the yankees and the nationals
kick off the kick off the mlb season
in an empty stadium and they kick off
the season by
kneeling not for the national anthem but
before the national anthem while holding
a very very very very very very very
long black cloth
which has solved all of our problems
murica
amazing they all melt now why were they
kneeling they were kneeling to protest
systemic
racism systemic racism the vaguest most
weasel
word weasel phrase used in american
politics today it means virtually
nothing
as john mcquarter has said as glenn
lowry has said the term systemic racism
has very very little meaning
it's deliberately designed glenn lowery
the the professor at brown university
who happens to be black
he pointed out in my program yesterday
that the term systemic racism is
basically just a way to silence debate
because by saying systemic racism you
now suggest that anyone who disagrees
with your take is in fact a racist
so all the players who by the way are
disproportionately of color
i mean the the mlb is not
disproportionately black but it is
disproportionately hispanic and latino
the the mlb you have all these people
who are earning millions of dollars to
hit and throw a baseball
kneeling for the systemic racism of the
united states which is always wonderful
they knelt for it and they played a
beautiful video from morgan freeman
a social justice catechism right before
the game and frankly i'm looking forward
to the seventh inning neil
i think that'll be the new aspect of
major league baseball that's really
exciting instead of
standing for the national anthem i think
we should kind of just sit for it
generally
and also mostly for the seventh inning
stretch we need seventh inning stretch
is not woke enough
i'm sorry it's snacks of privilege you
even have time
to stretch how many people around
america cannot stretch today
because of income inequality how many
people around america
are forced not to stretch stretching is
for white people because yoga is a white
people thing
okay no more seventh inning stretch we
need to stop the seventh inning stretch
instead
we need to play donald glover's this is
america
and everybody needs to kneel it's the
seventh inning neil that's what we need
from now on
okay so morgan freeman led off the
season with a bizarre
meaningless video about empathy because
of course the implication is that if you
disagree with kneeling for america's
systemic racism you're not empathetic
right that is the goal of this
particular video change and create a new
canvas of optimism
empathy must lead the charge this moment
signifies our
charge our brotherhood our unity
equality and unity cannot be until there
is empathy
today and every day we come together as
brothers
as equals all with the same goal
to level the playing field okay there's
only one problem okay empathy is
actually kind of bad for politics the
reason that empathy is bad for politics
is because it leads you to empathize
with people that you are more likely to
like
as opposed to people you don't like okay
so first of all the pitch for empathy
is actually there have been several
books that are written on this social
science books
talking about how empathy is not
actually
the best thing for politics it actually
almost deactivates the reasoning centers
of your brain
because when you're empathetic you don't
actually create good policy this doesn't
mean
that feeling sympathy for people is a
bad thing it means that if empathy is
what drives your policy-making you're
probably not acting in a rational
fashion
but the the real goal here is of course
not to generate empathy the real goal
here is to suggest that if you disagree
with the idea that america is
systemically and institutionally racist
you're not an empathetic person and
therefore you're a bad
cruel and callous person right the the
idea is that that
empathy is really about me it's really a
moral statement about what kind of good
person
you are and you can't watch baseball
until you say it along with morgan
freeman
you can't you can't just watch a game
and be distracted which is the goal of
sports
now listen none of this is to say real
obviously i'm being incredibly sarcastic
none of this is to say that players
don't have a right to speak they do
yeah i think that every player has a
right to speak just like every other
american i think also their words should
be taken
with exactly um the same amount of
seriousness that their expertise
on the subjects dictates so when it
comes to actually hitting a curveball
the actual art of hitting a curveball
i'm not an expert on that and when i
sound off about it you should take it
with a grain of salt
right i flamed out as a baseball player
at age 12. but
when i talk about you know systemic
systemic racism in the united states
it's meaning
economic inequality things that i've
actually spent years studying
then probably should take it a little
bit differently than a baseball player
who spends zero time studying it
but knows that they're supposed to kneel
for the morgan freeman
social justice invocation before a
baseball game
yeah that we don't have to take
everybody's opinion with the same amount
of seriousness
but we are now being dictated to really
by the corporation that is mlb
right it's not really the players so
some of the players are doing this kind
of stuff and you take them with about as
much seriousness as they deserve what's
actually happening right now
is that the major corporations have
decided just like all major corporations
across america that if they virtue
signal an incredibly vague fashion about
things that social justice warriors want
then they can buy off the social justice
warriors that's really the goal
the goal here is not about forwarding
any particular any particular good in
the united states
the goal is avoiding the blowback it's
the same reason you see so many
corporations across the united states
paying rob and d'angelo to educate their
people on diversity
they don't actually care what robin
deangelo has to say they're just trying
to limit their liability
it's the exact same thing with regard to
these major sporting
events and teams and corporations their
goal is to avoid public
blowback they don't want to be called
out for not being empathetic enough
so if instead they quote unquote lead
the charge by saying incredibly vague
things with no actual commitment to do a
thing
with no actual prescription well then
they've fulfilled their pledge
they've been shamed into repeating and
believing
and this is why you see the the boston
red sox unveiled a giant black lives
matter logo
at fenway park yesterday i mean enormous
right outside fenway park no really just
perfect perfect like again the basic
idea that black lives matter is utterly
uncontroversial
the group black lives matter is a
neo-marxist organization
the semantic overload that has been
placed on the phrase black lives matter
is deliberate
okay when when folks in the black lives
matter movement say they want to tear
down the entire
structural system of the united states
they are not lying about that
and then the idea is if you say well i
don't agree with that then you must not
agree black lives matter it's all
semantic overlord
overload game playing so the red sox are
engaging this do you actually believe
that the red sox believe the entire
system has to be torn down
in ibram candy and how to be an
anti-racist fashion do you believe that
i don't believe that this is just woke
virtue signaling so that people will say
oh look at the red sox look how much
they care
it's about the empathy and the feelings
okay so at least i will say this at
least the yankees and the nationals
didn't know for the national anthem
right they knelt before
so kneeling for systemic racism is
stupid because america's not
systemically racist
it isn't america is one of the most
tolerant countries on the planet
black americans are the richest black
people on planet earth it is not
particularly close
the the system of the united states is
built around the notion of equal rights
we're not talking about the history of
that of the of the failure of
application of that principle we're
talking about right now in 2020
america is not a systemically racist
country the presence of inequality does
not mean that all disparity is
discrimination
and so i have problems with the basic
premise that everybody's supposed to
kneel for systemic racism
especially when the case that's being
used even the george floyd case that is
not evidence of systemic racism i'm
sorry
there's not evidence that derek chalvin
who is apparently a very bad cop
was not just being a very bad cop he was
actually being a vicious racist who was
targeting black people
if the evidence is not in even on that
but even if he were
that would not implicate law enforcement
across the country
the 800 000 law enforcement officers
across the country and that would not
implicate
the the generalized system of american
rights
duties and institutions okay but at
least the yankees and nationals didn't
know for the national anthem you can't
say the same for mookie bats
so mookie betts is a terrific terrific
baseball player
he plays for the los angeles dodgers and
mookie betts
is kneeling for the national for the
national anthem he just by the way
signed
a contract with the dodgers worth 365
million dollars
365 listen you can be rich and you can
still spot flaws in the united states
but if what you're saying is that the
system of the united states is deeply
broken
while you are currently kneeling for the
national anthem getting no blowback
and picking up 365 million bucks to boot
yeah that's a heart that's a hard push
that's a hard push right there
okay by the way mlb is doing more than
this right there's the corporate i talk
about the corporate virtue signaling
we'll get to what
mlb is doing corporately in a second
first let's talk about one
easy way to make your health better i
mean these days you should be concerned
about your health
and good health starts with good habits
one of those good habits making sure
that your teeth are clean
believe it or not failure to clean your
teeth properly it's actually been linked
to things like heart disease it actually
creates serious health problems not just
in your mouth
quip makes it easy to keep your mouth
the way it is supposed to be
by delivering all the oral care
essentials you need to brush and floss
better
the quip electric toothbrush has time
zoning vibrations
with 30 second pulses to guide a densest
recommended two minute routine there's
even a size down version for kids
paired with quips anti-cavity toothpaste
and mint or watermelon you get all the
ingredients teeth actually need and none
they don't
quip also has an eco-friendly refillable
floss with a dispenser you keep for life
an expanding string that helps to clean
in between
you get all this amazing amazing stuff
when you go to get quipped.com
shapiro you get your first refill for
free it's your first refill for free at
get quip
dot com shapiro get quip dot com
shapiro they've got brush heads and
toothpaste and floss refills they're
automatically delivered on a dentist's
recommended schedule
every three months for just five bucks a
piece a shipping is free
join over three million happy customers
practice good oral care easily and
affordably
with quip starting at 25 bucks and if
you go to get quipped dot com slash
appear you get that first refill for
free
go check them out right this very
instant okay so
mlb has gone further than this so
mlb has now issued a
bunch of regulations on what is supposed
to appear
on the field according to sports
illustrated mlb will debut a black lives
matter stencil
on mountains across the league
apparently i don't
like i've been watching baseball all my
life they've never put a political logo
on the mound okay and the american flag
is not a political logo i'm sorry
anybody who
who suggests that black lives matter
which again is a term that has been
issued with semantic overload
right does black lives matter just mean
that we care about black lives because
then it's not political and it also
doesn't need to be said
because it's 100 true and pretty much
everybody agrees with it and if you
don't
then you are like one in 330 million
does black lives matter mean america
systemically racist cause that's highly
political and if black lives matter
reflects the organization it's even more
political than that
but i've not seen any political
messaging on the mound before
but apparently we are an unprecedented
point in crisis for black americans
which is just anti every piece of data
ever existed in human history
we are not at a point of existential
threat for black americans it is just
not true
there is no existential threat to the 42
million black americans the vast
majority of whom
are middle class or up okay the the idea
that the police are systemically hunting
down black people is a lie
it is a blatant overt lie they're a
grand total last year according to the
washington post
of 15 black men shot unarmed by the
police
the majority of those cases is where the
person was attempting to steal a weapon
off a cop
or was attempting to use another object
in order to harm a cop like driving a
car or something
and by the way in all the other cases
the cops were under investigation
and so the the entire idea
that law enforcement is hunting down
black people is just not true okay but
um but apparently it's a point of
existential crisis which is why
every major corporation now has to
infuse
the stuff that was supposed to be
distractions from politics in real life
right
we have to infuse all of that with these
deeply and and apparently
universally upheld apolitical messages
that happen to be very very political
okay the
sports illustrated reports mlp will
debut a black lives matter stencil on
mounds across the league in its opening
week
according to the washington nationals
the stencil will first appear on
thursday
the nationals in conjunction with major
league baseball stand with the black
lives matter movement
and will utilize the platform and
national stage of opening day to express
support for the fight against systemic
racism
and injustice so there it is right it's
all about america's systemic racism
and injustice and if you don't believe
this well you're gonna watch baseball
and you're gonna see it anyway just like
you see it when you watch the nba and
it's on the sidelines
mlb will also allow players to sport a
social justice message on their jersey
for opening day
according to espn's howard bryant united
for change and blm
are among the approved phrases to be
written on jersey patches per bryant
i also look forward to unborn lives
matter
i think that one will be real good i
think free hong kong should appear
as well like really let's just make this
as political as humanly possible
or alternatively what's happening with
these corporations is they feel like
they're gonna make a quick buck
because capitalism always makes its buck
now again if i sound upset about this i
am i mean i am upset about this
you have every right to do it your
corporation you can do it i don't have
to like it
and i can also point out i think it is
bad for the country when every area of
american life becomes overtly political
and you are forced to take a position on
deeply controversial issues
and you're supposed to actually not even
take a position you're supposed to
acknowledge and repeat that america is a
systemically racist country in order to
watch a damned baseball game
it's an absurdity it's an absurdity and
by the way this is of course
the going message of the nba as well
they've put black lives matter on the
side of the court so if you watch a
basketball game now you're going to be
messaged
too by people who suggest that america's
systemically racist in a league that is
black and where the average salary is
millions of dollars
now again none of this is to none of
this is to fail to recognize that
problems still exist in the united
states of course they still exist of
course there are still races
of course bad things happen to people on
the basis of race sometimes
but the notion that america is
systemically racist and that lebron
james is going to lead the charge
okay lebron james i'm sorry he's just
not a good spokesperson for this stuff
he isn't
okay lebron james yesterday he put out a
statement about he said black lives
matter isn't a movement
it's a walk of life it's a walk of life
and then he went further
he actually said it's not a movement
because there has been no movement for
black people in america
lebron james one of the richest black
men on planet earth
who grew up in apparently pretty
impoverished circumstances
and has risen to become not only one of
the most powerful voices in the country
but also one of the richest voices in
the country
apparently there's been no black
movement no movement for black americans
according to lebron james
which um read a book here's lebron james
a lot of people kind of use this analogy
talking about black lives matter is a
movement
it's not it's not a movement when you
black it's not a movement
it's a lifestyle we sit here and say
it's a movement and okay how long is
this movement gonna last don't stop the
movement
no this is a walk of life when you wake
up and you black you
that is what it is it shouldn't be a
movement it should be a lifestyle this
is who we are
and we understand it i don't want to
hear i don't like the word movement
um because unfortunately in america and
society
there ain't been no damn movement for us
there ain't been no movement
there hasn't been a movement for black
americans there hasn't
really really weird
because if there hasn't been a movement
for black americans i have been reliably
informed by the new york times
that slavery was at the root of the
american
experiment i've been reliably informed
by every historic source in human
history
that black americans used to be held as
slaves and then black americans were
kept
in abject poverty and segregation for a
hundred years
and now i have an extraordinarily
powerful black man
on my tv who earns hundreds of millions
of dollars
like a year right through advertisement
and all sorts of other venues
and by the way he's done a lot of great
charitable work by the way lebron james
and i hear from him there's been no
movement for black americans none
zero curious curious i feel like i'm not
being fed
a line that is true here but again if
you refuse to acknowledge that that line
is truth
if you refuse to suggest that america is
a systemically racist country today
if you refuse to acknowledge then of
course you are unwoke and by the way if
you point out that you think that
this very fraught battle the best place
to fight that
might not be you know on the field
itself like if you want to have these
conversations off the field go for it
enjoy but when i turn into a baseball
game i actually won a baseball game
then you are apparently unwoke and and
problematic and and also very political
it's just as political to say you want
to watch sports without politics
as it is to say that every single player
in the nba
and the mlb and the nfl ought to mirror
the sentiment that america is a
systemically racist country
this sort of stuff is designed to divide
americans it is they're taking away uh
they and by they i mean the corporations
i mean the social justice warriors i
mean the sports media i mean many of the
players they're attempting to divide the
country by specifically taking
apolitical areas of american life and
making them incredibly political
it makes the country worse there are
plenty of ways to have these
conversations we have them
every single day in this country every
single
day or have you not noticed but
apparently unless everything becomes
political
then the country is worse off well we'll
see how that goes i have a feeling that
is not the case
in just a second we'll get to other
social justice warrior stories from the
world of sports
get to that in just one moment first
let's talk about the fact that hiring
can be really difficult so why not make
it as easy as possible on yourself i
mean this is a really vital volatile
time in the economy if you're looking
for a job or if you're an employer
looking for a great employee
you need to connect this is why you need
a zip recruiter
housing wire could relate they needed an
ambitious reporter to cover news stories
on the us mortgage and housing markets
they used zip recruiters smart matching
technology to find people with the right
experience for the job in fact
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within in the very first day that's how
housing wire found alexandre roja
alexandra never imagined she could get a
reporter job in the middle
of the cove 19 pandemic because hiring
was basically frozen but she did
in fact find her dream career at housing
wire
zip recruiter helped alexander find the
right job they helped housing wire find
the right person
for their roll fast we use zip recruiter
right here at the daily wire so say that
you have
a producer who makes consistently bad
decisions in his personal life and
perhaps
perhaps producer nick those decisions
maybe extend into the workplace
that might force you to go look at
places like ziprecruiter
for their replacements ziprecruiter
makes sure that i have the best
employees
on this show it also makes sure that the
best employees can find us
see how zip recruiter can help you hire
try it now for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
dailywire all right so other social
justice warrior nonsense from the world
of sports the washington redskins have
renamed
they're now called the washington
football team i'm not kidding that's a
real thing
redskins it wasn't just that the term
redskins was offensive
now again there are polls that have been
done over the past 10 years it shows the
native americans did not care about this
issue there was a poll done about seven
years ago showed nine out of ten native
americans
did not only didn't care they actually
kind of thought that the name was was
cool
because you had a bunch of people who
were actually rooting for a team named
after native americans
but the washington redskins were
pressured because of george floyd or
something
into removing the name okay fine i
understand like you think that one's
offensive but here's the problem
there is no limiting principle to
renaming anything that could possibly be
found offensive
so washington could not find a new name
this is not the onion
it's not the babylon b the washington
team could not find a new name
they've renamed themselves the
washington football team
so i designed a logo for them that
really emphasizes
the team aspect of it and uh and the
logo looks a little something
like this looks like that right there
you see like washington
football team big t right there in the
middle it looks like wtf but actually
it's wft right the t is just big in the
middle
what i think we've gone woking a little
too much here guys
the washington football team exciting
exciting stuff
established in 1932 they won't change
their color scheme they're still going
to use burgundy and gold
but apparently the rebranding process
takes 12 to 18 months
and according to terry bateman the
franchise's new executive vice president
chief marketing officer he says if you
want to do it right
you got to take a deep breath take a
step back go through the process we want
to do it right
we just couldn't figure out what the
hell to call the team so we're now the
washington
football team oh we america getting
better
one stupid renaming at a time well done
well done
by the way in other politics and sports
anthony fauci throughout the first pitch
at the
washington nationals new york yankees
opening day game
uh it didn't go great for him so let's
let's put this out there let's you know
anthony fauci's 80 years old
i wouldn't expect him to fire in a
fastball but um there are a few
kind of oddities about this one is he's
wearing a washington nationals mask in
the middle of a completely empty stadium
which you don't actually need to do and
second of all it's not a good first
pitch i mean let's just point that out
is that important absolutely not it's
not important but
that doesn't mean we can't make fun of
it i mean here he is throwing a first
pitch
the only first pitch i've seen that
really is as weak as this first pitch
barack obama threw a real weak first
pitch at the all-star game in what i
think 2011.
this is not good here from from anthony
fouch he gets up there he really
flattens the curve
here he is throwing up and there it goes
right down the first base line
and fake crowd noise cheering that on so
anthony fauci by the way
the reason that it is incredible anthony
fauci has we do
it seems like we keep doing this over
and over because of trump and people
buying votive candles of robert
of robert miller if voucher won't
perceive to be at odds with trump
would there be anybody who's worshiping
fouchy at this point of course not you
don't see deborah burks throwing out the
first do you
anybody who's actually serving in the
administration is not worthy of throwing
out the first pitch only when fauci
opened a gap between himself and trump
was there this feeling that fauci was
now national hero number one again to
the point where he's throwing out first
pitches
it was you know the good news is that
fauci ensured once again that nobody
could catch anything
by the way i i just i'm wondering like
without you being celebrated as
a national hero like i'm glad that he
served the country in a lot of ways
right he helped solve
hiv and he's actually done an enormous
number of very good things in his life
but i mean the handling of the pandemic
if it's so bad for for most americans
fouchy was in the president's ear for
months on end
at some point you know you've got to say
that it's not going that great either
it's going greater ink on that great by
the way that was the worst that was the
worst for
first pitch since um 50 cent through on
out at the
at the cubs game a few years back lord
the mets game yeah didn't it did not go
well
yeah it was pretty similar i will say
that he got a little more distance on
his throw than fouchy but uh but 50 cent
is
is probably in his 30s vouchers in his
80s so to be fair
now not to uh not to shoeshine the
president here but the president does
have a better throwing motion there's a
video that came out yesterday
in which he's throwing with mariana
rivera so here we can compare a 70 year
old
man throwing a baseball to mariana
rivera with an eight-year-old man
throwing a baseball at the at the
national game he's got a pretty good
motion i mean i'll admit that the
president of the united states has a
fairly decent motion
right there all of this is silliness but
baseball should be the great distraction
it is no longer the great distraction we
have to load up the social justice
messaging
also every element of american life
should be turned into social justice
messaging
to the point where everything becomes
entirely stupid there's a
singer-songwriter i'd never heard of
named conan gray
conan gray apologized yesterday for his
use of emojis
his use of emojis he said many of you
have brought to my attention my use of
tan emojis
i apologize to anybody who was hurt by
my use of emojis that you believe
are too dark for me to use i am mixed
race i chose to use the emojis that i
felt best represented
my skin tone most of you have never met
me in real life and are unaware of how i
look in person i am not pale i am not
white i am mixed race
i was only trying to find an emoji with
a skin tone that felt most accurate to
me in my background
so um this guy's now apologizing for the
use of emojis we've made the country
better gang
everything is moving in the right
direction
i i feel excited everything has to be
political emojis
sports hollywood has to get even more
political michael b jordan
the major star of creed among other
movies he came out he said that
hollywood has to defund the police
that's exciting stuff he said hollywood
has to divest from the police and invest
in black talent and careers and hire
independent security firms apparently
very easy for michael b jordan who is uh
who's being taken care of by studios in
terms of his security
so good good times from michael b jordan
again
the country is just getting better can't
you feel the wokeness healing the
country
can't feel the wokeness oozing out of
the pores of america
covering us all up in a great
uh a great wondrous coding of protective
joy
and just and just binding the country
together i feel like we're doing so much
better now don't you
everything is just way better right now
in every way the sierra club by the way
is apologizing for john muir so that's
exciting too
like every aspect of sjw nonsense now
has to be has to be humored
the executive director of the sierra
club apologized on wednesday for the
substantial role the group played in
perpetuating white supremacy
they condemned john muir for friendships
and views he had we're canceling john
muir now that's exciting stuff
that is because john muir was friends
with eugenesis i was kind of a racist
um but i i just have a question did they
found the sierra club because he was a
racist
nope but it doesn't matter sierra club's
not apologizing for john muir i guess
we're going to rename the high schools
since for all the harms the sierra club
has caused and continues to cause to
black people indigenous people and other
people of color i am deeply sorry
yeah the the the cultural revolution
continues a pace
okay in just a second we're going to get
to the situation in america's major
cities
because that can they're real world
things happening right now and none of
them are good
while we're focused on stupid the real
world continues on a pace
we'll get to that in just a moment first
let's talk about the fact that you don't
really want to go to an auto parts store
right now
rockauto.com it's much easier than
walking into a store and someone's
demanding quick answers to things like
is your odyssey an lx or an ex
and then they usually just have to order
the part online anyway and you have to
wait for it
and then you're probably paying too much
because you're going through the auto
parts store instead go check out
rockauto.com
which is the glorious interwebs rock
auto always offers the lowest prices
possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear the way that
airlines do
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts the rockauto.com catalog
unique remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you again that's rockauto.com
go check them out right now alrighty
we're going to get to
everything actual serious related
like look i think the culture wars are
serious because i think that that's
where a lot of the heavy lifting is done
if we have now made it that every
corporation in america must mirror
hard left social justice nonsense about
systemic racism and bigotry
then that does shift exactly how we live
but it also has real world consequences
because it turns out that if you suggest
america systemically racist
and that the police are the leading arm
of the systemic racism movement
it turns out that you are more likely to
want to get rid of the police which does
have some pretty significant real world
consequences we'll get to that in just
one moment first
it is that glorious time of the week
when we give a shout out to a daily wire
member
it is that time today it's garrett shaw
on instagram who has the correct recipe
for the perfect weekend
in this picture garrett's elite beverage
vessel is resting on a patio table
alongside a copy of my brand's spanking
new book how to destroy america in three
easy steps
the caption reads official bench shapiro
hell i'm starting my weekend
leftist tears tumblr well done my friend
drink well those are indeed excellent
choices thanks for the pick hope you
enjoy the book
my new book how to destroy america in
three easy steps is on sale right now
the book covers two fundamentally
different visions of america that we are
watching right now one says
america is basically a crap fest and has
always been a crab fest and will never
stop being a crap fest
because our fundamental principles our
lies our fundamental institutions are
racist
the other is the traditional view of
america which is that the declaration of
independence is right
that american history is flawed but
great and that the story of america is
the
attempt to live up to founding principle
that we we ought to have a culture in
which entrepreneurship and adventure
is valued in which we respect each
other's rights to speak freely
disintegrationists are trying to cancel
all of that stuff how to destroy america
in three easy steps
is about how to stop them go check it
out right now how to destroy america
in three easy steps you can pick it up
on amazon or barnes and noble
right now also hark and hear me out
backstage
is this very eve ah the hallowed all
backstage eve
join me and perhaps dog jasper and
possibly others
at 4 p.m pacific to watch as i attempt
to make salient points
all while artfully dodging cigar smoke i
will admit that i have made it as
a condition that we be in a socially
distanced room
and that people do not breathe smoke
directly into my face oh there's faux
masculinity with the nonsense and the
smoke breathing oh i'm such a man i'm
smoking a cigar yeah sure whatever
all right we'll get to that tonight but
go subscribe over at dailywire.com
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so there are real world consequences as
it turns out to a lot of the blm
messaging
if you believe america's systemically
racist if you believe the police are
systemically racist
the first best move is to get the cops
out of heavily minority areas
there's only one problem when this
happens then areas with high crime which
unfortunately are heavily minority
across the united states
immediately become more violent and that
is really not great
last night a teenager was shot and
killed in minneapolis near 38th and
chicago avenue
which is basically where george floyd
was murdered this boy's death is
according to mike tobin
who is a fox news international
correspondent the boy's death marks
minneapolis 38th homicide more than
doubling last year's total of 17.
so in order to fight police brutality
they removed all the cops
and twice as many people have been
killed in minneapolis as were last year
well done everybody so like apparently
the legacy of black lives matter
in minneapolis is the riots that that
hollowed out a lot of the industrial and
commercial centers
a a perpetual feeling of crime on the
horizon and an increased murder rate
seems like life is getting better in
minneapolis as a result of all of this
you can see the progress happening in
real time it's pretty fantastic
also progress happening in seattle
according to ryan tevedra over at daily
wire the trump administration
is having to send an elite tactical team
to seattle to serve as backup for the
law enforcement officials
already there after the
democrat-controlled city has failed to
stop violent riots in recent days
the new york times reports the special
response team is being deployed
similar to the tactical teams currently
operating in portland agents from the
special response team
operated under u.s customs and border
protection are typically deployed for
intense law enforcement operations
similar to the agency's boar tech group
that is operated in portland the agents
will be backing up
the federal protective service which
said in a statement the cbt
cbp team will be on standby in the area
should they be
required over the weekend violent
rioters injured at least a dozen seattle
police officers and caused significant
damages to numerous businesses
and attacked multiple police stations so
things have been going great in seattle
when the mayor calls off the police
shockingly crime rises
who would have thunk such a thing so
things been going great in seattle
things actually went so great in chicago
that the chicago mayor
actually signed an agreement with
president trump to increase the federal
footprint in chicago so remember when
she was saying that it was
basically the feds terrorizing chicago
well lori lightfoot at the same time was
negotiating an agreement with the feds
to bring in more resources
which is just perfect apparently
according to daily wire president donald
trump reportedly phoned chicago mayor
lori lightfoot on wednesday night to
hash out details of a surge of 200
federal agents
designed to help chicago officials
control a dramatic uptick in gun
violence that has taken place in the
city
since the end of may the chicago sun
times reports the pair spoke about an
agreement to send 200 federal agents
mostly from the fbi atf u.s marshals and
dea
to assist the chicago pd in handling
crime in a number of target
neighborhoods
wracked by recent gang activity
lightfoot fought federal assistance
but after a gang-related mass shooting
outside of a funeral home 15 mourners
wounded tuesday night
lightfoot seemed somewhat more open to
the idea of receiving federal assistance
shocker so now the sun time says trump
and lightfoot are in agreement over the
strategy of sending in agents to plug
into existing operations so in other
words it was all for show
lori lightfoot is perfectly happy to
accept federal agents in her town just
doesn't want to say that out loud
because trump
which is demonstrative of the fact that
everyone right left and center knows the
only way to stop criminal activity
is with law enforcement but we're going
to lie about it to pretend that
america's systemically racist
that is the goal this resulted in
chicago protesters being very angry at
the mayor last night they went out
outside of the
mayoral offices and protested in large
numbers
a lot of white people protesting there
see how many white people there are in
this crowd a lot of white people
not all of them wearing masks you still
can't visit grandma in the hospital
but we can have these mass protests in
close proximity with a lot of people not
wearing masks a lot of dancing going on
it really is just a giant street party
guys people shouting in close proximity
to one another which is exactly how code
gets passed
things are just going great out there
the country's falling apart but things
are going
fantastically you can see people dancing
in the middle there half of them not
wearing masks really good stuff
in order to combat this lori lightfoot
has now announced
that the city of chicago is going to
remove statues
of christopher columbus so problem
solved guys problem solved christopher
columbus who's been dead for like
550 years that guy he's gone
he's down problem solved chicago is now
non-violent
so they removed the christopher columbus
statue from the city park just by the
way a few days
after there were near riots there that
injured a bunch of police officers
according to the hill crews came around
1am a few dozen people cheered when the
statue came down a few hours later not
clear where the statue is going to be
taken
because western civilization arriving in
the western hemisphere was apparently a
very bad thing
it was apparently really really bad the
move is irreversible from lightfoot who
initially opposed taking down the statue
on the grounds it would erase the
history of the italian explorer she's
rejected calls to rename columbus day
holiday
that rejection will last approximately
another 7.2
seconds america getting better by the
hour the unbelievable hypocrisy of
my town is completely out of control let
me call in the feds also let me cave to
the
the rioters and looters and protesters
at every available opportunity
is pretty incredible it's pretty strong
stuff meanwhile in portland
the situation continues to unravel
continued riding last night because it
was
a night ending and why meanwhile
portland mayor ted wheeler who's being
called a fascist
by the people he was allowing to riot
and loot went on cnn and said that the
problem here is of course you wait wait
for it wait for wait the problem is
the orange guy yeah it's not the rioters
and the looters who are taking over
blocks of downtown portland
and trying to destroy federal property
and engaging in mayhem the problem is
trump and he's a meanie and he's super
mean and he's orange and he's bad and
he's mean
and also bad in orange here's ted
wheeler with idiot chris cuomo
the president is using these federal
forces
as his own personal militia i believe
for the purpose
of political grandstanding he's doing
this he's creating the chaos
in democratically controlled cities so
ironically he can point to the chaos
and then say look those democratically
controlled cities are in chaos
and i and only i can stop the chaos
i i think this is uh abhorrent and it's
a
clear political stunt guys he's creating
the chaos
trump is creating it in all the
democratic cities it's crazy just sort
of like until
trump was president there was no chaos
in any of these cities ever chicago was
a
was just a wonderful utopian
landscape until trump became president
and also portland which has not had a
republican mayor in forever
like i think literally ever portland is
it was doing great and then trump you
know these riots it's all about trump
it's all about
ted wheeler the world's worst mayor
there's heavy competition for that title
right now is it lori lightfoot hmm
it could also be keisha lance bottoms in
atlanta could be bill de blasio new york
really is a garbage show it could be
mayor garcetti here in my hometown of
los angeles could be jenny durkin in
seattle
but wheeler's really up there i mean
there are a lot of bad mayors they all
have a d next to their names
oddly enough i can't explain quite why
yeah sure it's trump's fault it's
trump's fault your city's been burning
for two months and it's trump's fault
for sending in people to stop the
burning pretty incredible stuff here
so everything is going really well but
the important thing is that we have put
up banners that say black lives matter
everywhere
and we have emboldened people who wish
to defund the police increasing violence
problems solved america on the right
track i'm feeling pretty optimistic at
this point
aren't you and if you're not feeling
optimistic what's wrong with you what's
wrong with you
if you just want to watch a sporting
event without being clubbed over the
head with a brand of left-wing politics
that castigates america as evil
what's wrong with you don't you
understand this is how we make america
better is by making it more violent
more polarized more divided by
suggesting our fellow americans are all
racist sexist bigot homophobes and that
the entire american system which has
built unprecedented wealth prosperity
tolerance and freedom
that system needs to be torn down to the
shreds i can feel the progress can you
can you feel the progress i'm feeling it
i think everybody else is too
meanwhile kovit continues to surge
across the country now there's some
misinformation that's being put out
there about about the covid search that
is currently happening
i i think that this misinformation it's
pretty stunning that it's coming from dr
deborah burke who's been pretty accurate
about this stuff so yesterday
dr burks suggested the surge across the
country is three new yorks
no it isn't it isn't statistically
speaking it is not three new yorks
if it were three new yorks we would be
seeing approximately seven thousand
deaths today
because when we were looking at new york
we were seeing like
up to 1 500 deaths a day and 20 and like
2 900 deaths a day
total 3 000 deaths today total across
the entire the entirety of the united
states
it's not three new yorks the total death
numbers yesterday were about 1200 that
was the total reported deaths
it's one new york but it's spread out
over the other 310 million people
which is bad but if we could not
exaggerate the case that'd be really
nice here's dr debra burks
we already starting to see some
plateauing in these critically four
states that have really suffered
under the last four weeks so texas
california arizona and florida those
major metros and throughout their
counties and i just want to make it
clear to the american public
what we have right now are essentially
three new yorks with these three
major states and so we're really having
to respond
as an american people and that's why you
hear us calling for mass
and increased social distancing okay so
i'm all in favor of the social
distancing and the mass squaring i have
been all along
i've been following exactly what the
experts and supposed experts have been
saying
this whole way okay but we're not facing
three new yorks that's not accurate it's
not we're not seeing the ico is
overwhelmed
for all the talk and anecdotal talk
about icu's being overwhelmed in places
like houston it has not happened in fact
cases are now receding caseload is
receding
in places like houston it's receding in
arizona so
that's just not accurate okay by the way
i am amused and bemused
by the media coverage suggesting that of
course the bad guys here are ronda
sanchez in florida greg abbott in texas
and doug ducey in arizona
completely ignoring the fact that your
coronavirus leader in the clubhouse
right now among states is california
which is now engaged
in a second lockdown which is exciting
stuff gavin newsom somehow has escaped
all of the blowback that all of the
republicans are getting i can't believe
it
all three of the republicans i just
mentioned have seen their coronavirus
handling numbers absolutely tanked gavin
newsom's still up at 58
okay it's real bad here in california i
live in l.a county that's basically the
epicenter of the united states
in terms of coronavirus cases and yet
the press are not focused in on la
i can't imagine why could it be because
of the democratic mayor
and the democratic governor and the
entirely democratic state
it's incredible how ron desantis greg
abbott and doug ducey are responsible
for california and trump too it's all
trump's fault
it's also incredible how trump somehow
convinced everybody in spain to act so
irresponsibly they got a second wave
this is from the uk sun today spain
admits coronavirus second wave may be
underway
as uk airbridge could be axed in france
threatens to close the border there was
971 new cases yesterday 241 more than
the previous day
a record since the end of the country's
state of emergency you can't just look
at the raw numbers by the way the united
states has many many more tests than any
other country on a raw level
so what you really have to look at is
the directionality the uk sun revealed
the surge could lead to the collapse of
an air bridge between the uk
and spain meaning british tourists could
be forced to quarantine upon their
return home and
spain and france are closing their own
borders to each other
so that is exciting stuff meanwhile
france is experiencing its own second
wave
according to the uk express france is
having a second wave and emmanuel macron
is panicked as coronavirus outbreaks hit
a dreaded milestone
on wednesday france's health ministry
said a further 998 new confirmed coven
19 cases had been recorded
over the past 24 hours heightening
concerns about new flare-ups
of the epidemic fears of a second wave
have increased after
after the directorate general of health
warned the circulation of the virus is
increasing
after france recorded 208 currently
active coronavirus outbreaks on tuesday
also by the way japan experiencing a
second wave
according to france24.com japan saw a
record 366 new cases of coronavirus
recorded
in the capital on thursday france 24
correspondent michael penn says the
national government seems to be
prioritizing economic concerns by
opening up the country but tokyo's
governor is urging people to exercise
caution and stay indoors none of this is
to say that any of these countries
are wildly mishandling this thing but
when you see the same pattern everywhere
which is just giant spike and then it
recedes and then you're seeing the
second wave start to begin
you have to start to say nobody has a
great handle on this thing and paul
krugman has an idiotic column at the new
york times saying why can't we handle
this the way italy handled it
italy has a higher death per million
rate than the united states i've seen
the same thing said
about countries like uk the one you're
never allowed to mention of course is
sweden sweden has a higher deaths per
million rate than the united states
but right now they're experiencing
virtually no death like none even though
they have a significant caseload
because it's already run through
vulnerable areas of the population and
this is the common theme
is that places like new york it killed
everybody so is there going to be a
second wave as they reopen we don't know
yet we're starting to see a second bit
of an uptick in places like
massachusetts by the way
right which again was supposedly one of
the states that handled this beautifully
but don't worry andrew cuomo is on the
scene to stop everything bad from
happening andrew cuomo the world's
greatest governor
when he's not creating weird paper mache
mountains that symbolize
tens of thousands of dead and when he's
not putting out weird posters glorifying
himself
as the greatest governor in the world
that says new york is love and crap like
that
andrew cuomo is deciding what bars can
and cannot serve so
remember in new york the bars are
supposed to be closed right you're not
supposed to be in a bar
drinking in proximity with other people
because this is a chief vector of
transmission
the problem is that bars want to stay
open in order to serve food
so andrew cuomo got mad because what
bars were doing
is they were basically saying this is
stupid right you're dictating to us what
kind of food we can serve in order to
serve alcohol so what bars were doing to
basically make fun of him they were
issuing what they called cuomo
menus and the cuomo menus included
things like
a bag of grapes it's like you have to
eat this bag of grapes if you're going
to drink alcohol
cuomo by the way acknowledges he cannot
force people to eat the food you just
have to order the food
in order to get alcohol at the bars so
cuomo now has his comeback his comeback
is
he is going to shut down any
establishment that doesn't sell
sandwiches
i'm not kidding about this he says that
if you're a bar and you
sell buffalo wings buffalo wings are not
sufficient for you to call yourself
a food serving establishment it has to
be sandwiches
also hot dogs do not constitute
sandwiches not kidding we now have an
official
new york government ruling on hot dogs
according to the new york state liquor
authority guidance
if you operate a restaurant or bar and
you understand that you must serve
sandwiches soups or other foods when a
patron orders an alcoholic beverage
other foods are foods which are similar
in quality and substance to sandwiches
and soups
for example salads wings or hot dogs
would be of that quality and substance
however a bag of chips bowl of nuts or
candy alone
are not it is a different food that is
similar in quality and substance as a
hot dog to a sandwich so the question
has been answered but andrew cuomo says
even that is not sufficient now he's
making a distinction
between wings and sandwiches here's
andrew cuomo great expert
explaining based on the science that
buffalo wings are different than
sandwiches in terms of nutritional
content to be a bar
you had to have food available soups
sandwiches etc
more than just hors d'oeuvres chicken
wings you had to have some
substantive food the lowest level of
substantive food were sandwiches
now that was the lowest but it had to be
more it couldn't just be wings it could
just do
what's incredible is that everybody
calls trump a fascist last i checked
trump wasn't issuing
giant national regulations about whether
you have to serve sandwiches or buffalo
wings
i mean like seriously what what what a
horror show cuomo is but don't worry
he's been great
at this we know he's been great because
he doesn't like trump and anybody
doesn't like trump
anyone who doesn't like trump is
fantastic okay we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content i have some assignments for you
in the meantime
so today there's two additional hours of
content plus you need to pick up a copy
of my book how to destroy america in
three easy steps amazon just lowered the
price and now's a great time to buy the
book
it was weird amazon had it like the
highest price book in the top 100
and finally they lowered the price which
was a little bit tardy but they did it
so you can get it now for like 18 bucks
so go check it out right now how to
destroy america in three easy steps plus
later today we have a daily wire
backstage a socially distant backstage
we'll be in the same room but i'm gonna
sit far away from the others and um and
they're going to not be allowed to blow
smoke at me which i'm excited about so
you have that as an assignment plus
subscribe over
for reader's pass at dailywire.com lots
of stuff for you to do this weekend
try to stay out of trouble if you don't
do any of it or if you do all of it and
we'll see you here next week i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam siyovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nico geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll give it a listen